one of my favorite moments of the entire
series
seeing all the ladies step up and just
so fun
can you feel the energy that i can see
watching that scene on set
because i don't know it was just like
the cuts were so perfectly
timed and the reaction shots and the bit
like everything just came together
better than i ever could have imagined
all of us women
we just really went in and committed to
it
i find it really fun to do those fight
scenes and luckily they do too
so the commitment was really contagious
and it's very cathartic and by that
point season finale like
i felt very much like i starlight and i
were the same person
you know with each episode when i get
back to filming i feel like i absorb her
more and more so
the catharsis and being able to even
fake beat up stormfront and what she
stands for in this season and just like
just the bad ass female component and
the fact that the boys are the ones who
are just
observing it like all around it was
so fun but also it was just so
satisfying you know it was also fun
from a personal perspective but it was
really fun because here i am you know
i've made such close friends out of my
castmates and i have these
these women like aya and karen who
i absolutely love and they're such
beautiful people and kind people
but then i also get the opportunity to
observe these women who have become my
best friends
kick ass and then i watch it on the show
and the music and it's just like i don't
know it's a little bit of a childhood
dream
coming true and it's definitely one of
those i have a lot of these moments on
set but that was probably
the peak of all of these moments where
i'm just like god this specific
job is so fun the things i get to do
i it's like playtime
you know it's so fun that i get paid for
it you know
i loved it you give us the fun to watch
i like that that it feels even more so
like fun with purpose
you guys are commenting on things that
are very real and very now
and i feel like being able to explore it
in such a heightened way sometimes makes
you understand even better than you
might have before
honestly what you just said is what
makes the show so fun for all of us
that's exactly it is that we just get to
do
fun things we get to the cast is really
like a family so we all get to work with
people we love
um get to explore the nuances of our
characters and relationships within the
show
but really just have fun and do wacky
things all while
making social commentaries that we
believe in and it's really the best
of all worlds for us it's so fun to make
it